in the upcoming reboot pray you'll be up
against a Mighty Morphin alien race
called typhoons these black shadowy
monsters come in different shapes and
sizes with each type possessing its own
special power in a recent playable prey
demo we mainly got time with just one so
be sure to hit that subscribe button for
more coverage on the others down the
road meet the mimic for stretchy
tentacles slapped on a midsection
they're like a mix between a headcrab
and those aliens from the movie edge of
tomorrow which are also called mimics
but these mimics are unpredictable brats
that lived frustrate you they'll outrun
you up on your face throw chairs puff up
and give you a nice slap they're like
riled up 10-year olds on a weeknight
before bedtime they won't go to sleep
easy and that's partly due to the fact
that they love love to play games they
play this one really cute game so cute
they'll jump on your chest and then
they'll shove a tentacle down your
throat drain the life from your body and
then use it to replicate itself adorable
tag is another mimic favorite only the
second you lose sight you're now playing
a game of hide and seek
because mimics mimic objects go figure
and it's this mimic mechanic that keeps
you on the edge of yours oh look a vase
yep and it's after those first jump
scares that you'll find yourself
whacking away at anything but you won't
have to hit every object like a nutcase
because once you've studied the waves of
the mimic you'll learn how to catch
their hiding spots because just like
panic filled little toddlers they're
really not that smart example you leave
a bathroom and see two trash cans at the
exit mimic and to a room and there's a
pair of shoes but a third shoe mimic and
when there's movement there is mimicking
because sometimes they're just a little
naive like really I totally saw that on
the flip side it could be a bluff
because mimics generally aren't alone
you may kill one and think the room is
cleared then you'll find yourself
cornered by four more that have been
waiting the whole time and that's
probably the most impressive part about
mimics is that they work together you
can even create a scene anything from a
caution wet puddle set up to see or
maybe you open a door and find a speaker
and plant resting on a table haha mimics
next thing you know you're out of ammo
and overwhelmed this guy knows what I'm
talking about and that's truly an
unsettling feeling looking at what
appears to be an empty room in reality
it isn't from a game development
standpoint it's a pretty clever way I'm
giving motives for whacking someone's
office chair while not looking like a
schizo jerk that's it for this piece on
mimicks if you liked it and would like
to see more down the road do like and
sub and for more on our prey coverage do
check out our overall impressions from
Lucy into more good stuff thanks for
watching
[Music]